SETH VARGO: In this episode
of the Secret Manager video
series, we'll talk about how
Secret Manager automatically
versions your secret payloads.
Should you pin your applications
to a specific version
or always use latest?
Stay tuned to find out.
[FUNK MUSIC PLAYING]
In Secret Manager, a secret
is a logical collection
of secret versions.
Versioning is a core
tenant of reliable systems
to support gradual rollout,
emergency rollback,
and auditing.
Secret Manager automatically
versions secret data
using secret versions,
and most operations
like access, destroy,
disable, and enable all
take place on a secret version.
While the parent secret
holds metadata information,
like name and
replication policy,
the secret version stores
the actual secret payload,
your secret data.
Once a secret
version is created,
its payload is immutable.
That means version
42 of a secret
will always contain
the same payload.
When a new secret
version is added,
it automatically becomes
the latest version.
So should your applications
pin to a specific version,
or should they just use latest?
To answer that question, I think
we need to bring in an expert.
[FUNK MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Rachana.
Thanks for joining us today.
RACHANA LINGUTLA: Thanks, Seth.
Thank you for having me.
SETH VARGO: So Rachana is
a software engineer who
works on Google Secret Manager.
OK, Rachana.
Earlier, I was
telling our viewers
about secret versioning
and the latest alias.
When should we pin
our applications
to a specific version, and when
would we use this latest alias?
RACHANA LINGUTLA: Sure, Seth.
To help answer that
question, let's look
at a hypothetical scenario.
Suppose we have an
application that
uses an API key to communicate
with a third-party service.
If the application was
using the latest alias,
Secret Manager would always
return the most recent value,
regardless of whether that
value was ready to be consumed.
If the application was
pinned to a specific version,
Secret Manager would
return the pinned version,
even if a newer version exists.
SETH VARGO: OK, but then
if I pay my application
to a specific
secret version, how
would I update the secret
used by that application?
Do I have to package and
rebundle and redeploy
my whole application?
RACHANA LINGUTLA: Actually, yes.
At Google, we believe
secrets are configuration,
and configuration
should be versioned
with the deployable artifact.
SETH VARGO: OK.
That kind of makes sense.
So that way if there's
a problem or a bug,
I can easily rollback,
and if I rollback,
my configuration would include
the old secret version.
So my application
is then bundled
in a known working
version, right?
RACHANA LINGUTLA: Exactly.
SETH VARGO: OK.
OK, so it seems like
the latest alias is not
good for production.
But it'd be really
useful when I'm
doing rapid iteration in
my development or staging
environments.
Is that right?
RACHANA LINGUTLA: Yes,
that's right, Seth.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thanks, Rachana.
OK.
Let's look at a
Google Cloud function
that accesses a secret using
the Secret Manager API.
While iterating in my local
development environment,
I'd instruct my Cloud Function
to access the secret using
the latest alias.
But when I'm ready to
move to production,
I would pin my deployment to
a specific secret version.
Secret Manager's
first-class versioning
helps you follow a
DevOps best practice
of reproducible deployments,
while the latest alias provides
a convenient method for rapidly
iterating during development.
That's all for this episode.
In the next episode, we'll
talk about the principle
of least privilege and
how Secret Manager can
help you get there.
Be sure to like, subscribe,
and click the bell
to get notifications
about new episodes.
For more tips and tricks
with Google's Secret Manager,
subscribe to Google
Cloud platform.
[FUNK MUSIC PLAYING]